An ABO protein that is severely shortened, right,
shortened at close to the very beginning. It's only
got about 1/4th of what it would normally
have. It only got the like position 250 out
of a total of roughly a thousand. We
are most likely going to end up with a non-functional
protein. Right. At this point we deleted like
three quarters of the ABO protein from this single
letter change in the DNA code. And as a result, we end up with blood type O.
Blood type O, the reason it's letter O,
the O represents the absence. Of a molecule here
that would normally be added by a functioning
protien. So, the ABO protien would normally add an
antigen to the red blood cells. But, because it's
non-functional nothing gets added. And, so we call that
blood type O.